welcome to Startalk I Neil deGrasse
Tyson your personal astrophysicist on
rare occasions I sit down to interview
someone whose presence is powerful
entertaining and enlightening all at
once and the conversation that comes out
of that encounter is so inspiring or
enlivening that we must depart from our
usual studio format in exchange for some
one-on-one time on one such occasion i
sat down with entrepreneur author and
podcaster Tim Ferriss that interaction
led us all at star talk to break format
for this special episode instead of our
usual panel of instudio expert guests
comedians and scientists what follows is
my uninterrupted conversation with Tim
from start to finish
Tim is best known as an angel investor
and advisor for startups and the most
notable startups he's either invested in
or advised our uber Twitter Evernote and
TaskRabbit he's also the author of
several books including the 4-hour
workweek of the 4-hour chef and tools of
titans for this first part of the
conversation we got to know about Tim
and the life that prepared him to become
such a prolific author so let's go to
that conversation now yes sir welcome to
Startalk thank you for having me you got
a podcast of your own well let me think
what would it be a name for that podcast
you know one of my friends suggested Tim
Tim talk talk which I vetoed
unfortunately for Kevin but it's called
the Tim Ferriss show the Tim Ferriss
show a really popular podcast and what
what like about it most is just how how
you have just as a general point of
philosophy you have kind of restructured
how people think about how they make
themselves what they are is that a fair
characters it's fair I try to do it it's
very personal plant major in this in
school you cannot you you invented this
i borrowed bits and pieces from a lot of
people in a Ben Franklin did something
your friend
my friend my good friend Ben and Ben go
way back I think the the
self-experimentation is really drawn
from a lot of different influences well
let's go back so when you grew up
yeah were you give me a geek underbelly
that like your friends didn't know oh
well my few friends that I had
definitely definitely friends yeah it
was a geek protocol I was I was born
premature out here on Long Island and
was very very small so I was badly
bullied as a kid up until about sixth
grade so you were bullied why what were
you what if what were you doing to be
bullied how was bullied because that was
the smallest kid in the class it was hit
that's it that's it and a lot of
physical issues respiratory difficulties
because I had lung problems when I was
born premature and you were sickly kid I
was a weak kid and that explains a lot
of things including affinity for
Dungeons & Dragons refuge in books
things you could do alone things you can
do alone things you can do when other
kids go out to recess so you're not in
the middle of the war zone and the books
largely end up because my family very
early my parents did something I thought
was very smart also a necessity which
was they said we don't have much budget
for new bikes or this so that but we
always have budget for books and that
meant that a trip to the bookstore
specifically to the remainder table was
really exciting for my younger brother
and for me personally and I gravitated
to marine biology specifically books on
sharks because out here on the East End
I had learned very early that Clint and
gets Clint who's the crazy shark hunter
and jaws was based on a guy named Frank
Mundus
who lived in Montauk and I went and met
Frank at one point my mom took me on a
field trip to go meet him and he was a
real character he was a shark hunter
later became a shark conservationist but
he wore an Australian outback hat had a
big hoop earring painted his toenails
and he was an excellent storyteller the
guy wasn't a scientist but he catalyzed
an interest
in marine biology and so I bought books
on sharks fish encyclopedias of all
different types when I had the
opportunity and so it's fair to say that
I was definitely a nerd
up until sixth grade then that summer I
gained weight all that happened before
sixth grade yeah oh yeah okay I'm
thinking you're in high school no no no
started college no this I'm making shark
functors this I'm thinkin you're older
of these is this this started very early
so I remember in third grade sitting on
the stoop with this this big hardcover
book I think it was called fishes of the
world and the substitute teacher at the
time told my mom he shouldn't bring that
book to school he'll destroy it and she
said you don't know my son he's not
gonna destroy that book so the interest
started really really early Wow okay so
you go from the bullied little kid in
the class to someone who's was on a
mission
yeah yeah but wait so was that science
element of this that was not an active
thought it was just really cool it was
just really cool yeah but I ended up
later as I learned more about it and an
interest a very narrow interest in apex
predators like sharks or anything that
was dangerous to man basically it so
apex
does that mean nothing is a predator to
it right so there would be they picked
whether they're being humans in a way or
humans are the most dangerous apex
predator no one really hopes us except
ourselves that's right right for sharks
so although human fatalities from sharks
are negligible but the the fact that
there were species that still demanded a
certain respect from humans was very
appealing to me and that then broadened
so I went from just looking at sharks to
more broadly fish and I want to be
marine biologist for the 15 15 years
that was a real close it was well that's
one just because it was cool and I read
about Jacques Cousteau and these various
people who were diving gathering samples
running analyses of various types and I
just found the entire implementation of
what I found in the classroom would be
very boring fascinating it's in the
sterile
context of a lot of the school classes
it didn't grab my attention but when I
was able to be presented in a story of
some type which is why Frank was so
interesting to me not because he knew
science but because he was good at at
grabbing attention whatever it takes
okay I'll take it we'll take it if it
gets you there who will take it so
that's how it started and it certainly
get me continued from there it ended up
veering in a sense by the time I got to
and we're skipping some stuff but by the
time I got to freshman year in college
it was neuroscience I was more
interested in neuroscience because that
was my first major actually because I
have Alzheimer's and Parkinson's on both
sides of my family
oh so I was able to watch to get in
there figure out the decline of
cognition firsthand and that terrified
me and I also wanted to try to help my
parents potentially or their brothers
and sisters is ensuing does that also
motivate you to make every day count it
does it does and it also motivates me to
not focus excessively on lifespan but
rather functional health span and
looking at how different types of
interventions can extend functional
health span which you can define across
a whole bunch of different parameters
but certainly not forgetting the
person's name you're sitting with five
minutes into a conversation will be part
of that so it certainly is a still as a
huge motivator so okay so now it's
coming into focus how this life path
this arc has come together in the books
you've written you're trying to to
motivate other people to make the most
and best of what they are and their time
and their investments mm-hmm and who and
what they can be like I got the list of
books here I mean one of these showed up
in my office actually oh did you set it
well I did not it was that was it the
the the 4-hour body formatting was that
the one no no the for our chefs
for chefs I would have in 2012 I got the
dates here if you don't remember 2012
no it's like these are big books they
are big books they are this know there
are choose your own adventure books
there buffets some very nonlinear in
that way but yeah they're big they're
big mm-hmm and so which of these would
you say so let's just spend a minute on
each on each book here okay so the
4-hour workweek yeah where were you
trying to go with that that book that
was an accidental book in the sense that
uh everyone writes books by accident
well it was accidental itself after my
senior thesis in college I'm on a native
English speaker acquisition of Chinese
and Japanese characters so was looking
at the semantics and and phonetic both
pathways and tools that a native English
speaker could use to accelerate the
acquisition of East Asian writing
systems and how many majors did you have
I had one so I started in neuroscience
we can talk about why I made the shift
but I was I was in psychology
technically with the specialization and
in neuro and then went to the East Asian
Studies department with a concentration
in Japanese okay the the 4-hour workweek
came about because it's starting in 2013
that's not right that's when I stopped
starting in around 2003 I was invited
back by an incredible professor I had
named professor Chou spelled Z SCH a you
amazing polymath of a guy we could talk
about him already polymath anymore
that's yeah he was an old world thing
yeah yeah find one in modern times
that's a fascinating man he's a
competitive figure skater congressman
took a couple of companies public and
was a revered professor at Harvard
Business School among other places also
taught computer science at Stanford
before that and I had been invited back
to his class to guest lecture twice a
year to talk about building bootstrap
startups as opposed to venture backed
outside financed startups and the notes
from that class as my life changed from
say 2003 where I was on the verge of
burnout because I was working on my own
company to 2005-2006
as my life changed the content of the
course or the lecture changed and it
turned lecture you've delivered that's
right it started off these are windows
into you
absolutely yeah for sure every every
book that I've written has been a book I
couldn't find for myself and I love that
there's 30 million books in the world
and there's one that hasn't been written
yet and I gotta write it yeah like if I
needed it it's kind of anxious you know
it's it's audacious and selfish its
self-interested innovation that's better
and at least if you're writing a book
that you yourself would have needed you
know you have a guaranteed readership of
one which is put your mom plus your mom
and so the the 4-hour workweek was
really the collection of notes from
those guest lectures assembled into a
book which was recommended by a few of
the students in the class and then by a
friend of mine who is an author but
after the senior thesis I had vowed not
to read anything longer than an email
after that because it crushed me I had a
very hard time with the thesis I'm very
very difficult time to the extent that I
took a year away from college actually
and I give a personal reflection on that
yeah so seven to see C's of masters and
a PhD thesis and I have some books each
one of those yeah was like giving birth
yeah nothing I know what giving birth is
like but if I were imagine it it's like
this is a piece of me coming out yes
there it is okay I gotta just go home
now I got to not do anything for like
three years
yeah I have to regenerate regrow myself
my mind body soul then we can have
another conversation definitely and it's
also like childbirth in the sense that
at least many of the women I know who've
given birth they're like alright not
doing that again and then a year and a
half years later here we are again this
I think that forget shame has to show up
with otherwise would you know we're
gonna be here first and last species
would've been gone long ago without that
they'll forget yeah so you've written
you've written a lot you've written
you've put together a lot of writing
you've been very prolific and it takes
yeah but it's more traditional it's like
I'm an expert on a subject yeah and then
there's some new stuff in the subject so
I write about it
you're creating an awareness that people
didn't even know they didn't have right
that affair it's totally ER and if you
look at the 4-hour workweek which is
basically an entrepreneurial exploration
of hidden assumptions governing behavior
which was influenced also by a bunch of
the professor's I had like Bart hobo who
studied among other things sugar
addiction published a lot of seminal
papers that ended up creating almost a
sub specialization within psychology
it's really about hidden assumption so
the 4-hour body was the same what are
the hidden assumptions that are limiting
the flower's body so we just shifted
books for our body 2010 that's 10 and
just to explain the whole four-hour
thing because it's a it's a blessing and
a curse and it sounds like an
infomercial product all I'll cover that
it so does Jesus let me be up with he
does so I had a number of titles for the
book the first book which was turned
down by 26 publishers by the way and did
it make a great folder it does yeah some
of them were so in violent unnecessarily
aggressive but turned down by it but
John Grisham has a folder like that yes
yeah they were early turned they were
fantastic at didn't feel fantastic at
the time but in retrospect good to look
at and I had about a half half a dozen
or a dozen titles and perspective
subtitles and the publisher and I
disagreed on on the preferred titles and
instead of having a really emotional
debate I said give me a week let me test
it I'm very good at testing and went on
to Google Adwords and created or I
should say bought domains for these
various book titles created
advertisements that had the book titles
as the headline the subtitles as the ad
text and at least at the time I haven't
used Google AdWords in a long time but
it would mix and match and do the
multivariate testing for you and then I
would look at the click-through rate and
if people clicked it just took them to
an under-construction page because I was
not testing the content of the page I
was testing the attention
the attention advantage of different
combinations of titles and subtitles and
at the time I was spending about two
hours a week managing the business that
I created which was later sold the two
hours seemed too unrealistic to the
publisher and I was like four hours and
they're like sure
four hour sounds great so I tested that
and the combination of that and the
subtitle performed many standard
deviations better than above everything
else and that's how I choose the that's
how that's how I ended up choosing the
title and sometimes you know that's
disappointing because we all wanted you
to say well I was a spark of genius that
came to me one night over a beer no no
it was the you actually applied
scientific principle yeah yeah it was a
few hundred bucks and in what it did is
it it overrode all the sparks of
stupidity that had generated a lot of
bad ideas
that's anyways what a doubt test it
that's right back what they come that's
right yeah when in doubt test it yeah
you want to come up just recently a
tribe of mentors I haven't read that so
what's that what's that about charmed
mentors is really a collection of
profiles of 130 or so what I would
consider world-class performers people
who are at the top of their respective
fields that could be sports it could be
poker it could be all of those things
business certainly singularly achieving
people singularly achieving people and
what distinguishes them and the way that
I was able to discern what distinguishes
them is by asking them all the same ten
or so questions and what I enjoyed about
that book aside from the fact that it
was nice to actually have 130 people
write the book for me
which was which I'm not gonna do for
every book but the first two biggest
secret of the first three boo brutalized
me so then I decided to take a little
breather on that and to see if it would
work and it did what's nice about that
is that you asked these people questions
you know what do you do when you feel
overwhelmed or distracted what have you
become better at saying no - over the
last five years how do you say no these
are always really poor people don't
realize the program
knows walking around out there yeah it's
really important yes it's really
important and they're our favorite
failures for instance what is what is
your favorite failure or a favorite
failure meaning a failure that in some
fashion set you up for a larger success
later and the profiles are organized in
such a way that you can spot patterns
because you'll you'll you'll see
commonalities across some of those
answers which means and this is
certainly been my experience
interviewing people on the podcast that
top performers in distinct fields often
share more in common than they do with
say the C players in their own field
there are a lot of shared
characteristics
so that's tribe mentors so that would be
that would argue strongly for training
people in school to have certain
attributes without specific reference to
a subject yes then you've set them loose
on whatever subject interests them and
then they they know how to tackle it how
to find it Adam now ascend to the top
totally agreed completely and the third
book the 4-hour chef is confusingly not
only about food it's about a framework
for learning say a series of steps that
one can use to tackle different subjects
or skills they could be it could be
facts and figures right declarative
knowledge it could also be procedural it
could be some type of physical skill and
I do think that's it's really important
not to convince someone that their
ability to learn is somehow siloed in a
single domain that's I think not just
paralyzing in some respects but it's it
creates blind spots and it's dangerous
so that's that's a reason also that one
of my most influential teachers was
someone I never met who is Richard find
them so I'm not a scientist I'm not a
physicist but going to Princeton also
almost an undergraduate as an
undergraduate the the interest began
with surely you're joking mr. Fineman as
a that's only book of in stay a radical
book and a big book either no it's not
sooner than your books by the way I've
almost let the record by far show us
more more quality
for sure and that books surely a joke he
was the vironment skinny books and and
what appealed to me so much about fine
and in the last couple years and I don't
do this kind of stuff ever but I
actually bought at auction a collection
of his encyclopedias when he build that
he owned and bought when he was 40 so
I'm 42 right now in the fact that he
bought these encyclopedias at 40 with
his track record and accomplishments up
to that point was inspiring to me that
he would still have not just these
references but he would memorize large
parts of things like peeta Britannica in
any case so Fineman appeal heaven his
encyclopedic set that's right some isn't
that he dies from his from his office
okay
and it just came up for auction it came
up very unusually for auction from a
private collection almost none of his
papers or belongings have ever gone up
for auction and there are few friends of
mine who like me are obsessed with a
handful of people including Fineman one
friend has actually given his his one of
his sons the middle name
find them just to give you an idea and
he brought it to my attention
he said just in case you haven't seen it
this is coming up I'm afraid to ask you
if you have kids what you named them
probably not it's a little scary at this
point in this conversation if I don't
eat daddy so no no fineman's yet but the
fact that he took this this curiosity
was more the curiosity than the
accomplishments that appealed to me and
applied it to safecracking applied it to
cryptography applied it to music I also
bought a bongo that proposed or not a
bongo a tambourine that he used in
Brazil but the memory of these things
yep-yep people don't see them much any
now it was very 1960s a Korean stereo
underappreciated very underappreciated
so that weird spelling - that's right
people gonna look up foot Tamborine for
something really cool but that's a whole
separate topic so the the and this ties
into your question about teaching people
to
learn or less say your comment rather of
giving people a toolkit and at the very
least convincing them that there are
certain principles that apply cross and
a cross-disciplinary way I think super
important and so so final inform he's
always been a reminder to take the
curiosity that might be focusing in one
place and try to take whatever I learn
and see if it applies elsewhere and
that's certainly the case with a lot of
the books it's it's taking something
that seems to work in one place and
trying to apply it in another and see
what happens
you got to wrap up this segment of star
talk coming up more my one-on-one
conversation with entrepreneur Tim
Ferriss see you in a moment
welcome back to star talk we've been
following my one-on-one conversation
entrepreneur Tim Ferriss let's get back
to it like crack team of researchers
tell me that you you've been into
science fiction so it's what prompted
that I've been interested I have loved
science fiction for a really long time
fantasy as well but science fiction
included and it started with a
recommendation from my mom who said that
I should read a stranger in a strange
land by Robert Heinlein and that really
captured my imagination and I felt like
there was a lot you could learn from it
as I also feel about a lot of the
science fiction I've read since doing
certainly if you want to learn about
leadership I think doing is a fantastic
book you don't have to read nonfiction
necessarily world-building minutes great
example of world building and all right
so did science fiction not to put words
in your mouth but did science fiction
enable you to think about possible
worlds that don't currently exist but
with some energy and investment and some
wisdom you might be able to get there
yeah and so in life a possible world
could just be a possible career path
that was not otherwise visible
definitely I thought that's absolutely
true and I think it gives you a lens
through which to look at present that
allows you to see possibilities that may
have been invisible to you before and
certainly a
lot of the who want to call them
predictions descriptions in science
fiction have found a home whether that's
a self-fulfilling prophecy or not as a
separate separate question but a fun
question oh yeah it's for the art
imitates life life imitates art
conversation but it's it allowed me to
look at things differently and I'm all I
enjoy finding prompts and tools that
allow or force me to look at things
differently and that's taking the form
of science fiction you can do a lot of
experiments with sensory substitution
and all sorts of weird things that we
could talk about that
definitely force you to perceive the
world differently we're getting there
yeah and the science fiction and love of
science fiction has has continued so
more recently after the classics tune
and so on you have people like Ted Chang
who has an amazing collection of short
stories I think it's called stories of
your life and other stories but his one
of his short stories story of your life
was adapted and turned into a film
arrival which is an incredible film that
gets into language and all sorts of
topics that that I that I appreciate and
it's not every film where a linguist is
the star the star that star and it's and
it's it's so it's so by the right just
to be clear there's a version there's a
movie with that title from the 1990s
starring Charlie Sheen yes so and then
there's one more weeds in the in the
2010s that's our arrival mm-hmm yeah
which which is an incredible story and
incredible film because it uses the
allure and the sexiness of science
fiction to delve into topics and
questions that it might otherwise be
very sterile like how does language
affect your thinking how does language
if at all affect your perception of time
and this came about because of our
attempt to communicate with aliens with
aliens that they were trying to
communicate with us who can indicate
with us what conversation rule basically
these were shock inkblot rape to
Graham's right and you know as someone
who who studied Japanese and Chinese and
so on as
under graduates specifically the writing
systems I just loved that and it's it's
a Trojan horse for getting people
interested in subjects that might
otherwise be too sterile so that's
another aspect of this course in a good
way in a great way in a way most
references to Trojan horses are viruses
computer viruses or Negev this is this
is a positive smog get in the door and
then you explore the new city you just
that's right this is benevolent idea
smuggling yes yes what's your
fascination with psychedelics is this
you have a background interest in
neuroscience I do yeah so is there a
connection there there is there is a
connection and it's it's it's also very
personal and I can talk about that but
I'll talk about the the neuroscience
first the the interest in neuroscience
that was actually one of the
contributing factors for also looking at
psychology first and when I was at
Princeton aside from Bartho Bowl and
some other professors who had an impact
on me I was attracted to the work of
Professor Barry Jacobs and Barry Jacobs
focused on among other things monoamine
neurotransmitters such as serotonin
looked a lot at certain and in sleep he
also chemistry of the mind
chemistry of the mind and he had looked
also quite closely at hallucinogens and
their impact on various various types of
mental functioning he didn't teach a
class for that he did not okay he didn't
think I don't know yes he did not but I
wrote one of my junior papers on the the
physiological similarities so the I
guess you could call it a biological
similarities at least as we measured
them at the time between LSD or LSD 25
and REM sleep it turns out there
actually there's a lot of there's a lot
of common ground which is really really
fascinating and could explain some of
the later findings related to not just
LSD but a lot of these these serotonin
2a agonists which a lot of these
psychedelics are meaning that they
activate or bind to these these certain
to
receptors there are many other receptors
that are their impact so but it's one
thing to have an academic interest in
who so genic so another thing that if
you're if you're sort of a life coach
yeah that implies there's some
practicality sure you can bring to bear
yeah and I I i definitely view myself
more as a a human guinea pig who reports
the findings more than life coach but
the the personal reason for looking so
closely at psychedelics and more
recently taking almost all the energy
and capital I was applying to startups
and applying it to science is that my
family aside from having Alzheimer's and
Parkinson's on both sides also has
severe depression on both sides whether
it's chronic treatment resistant or
bipolar and that is something that I
struggled with for many decades and it's
only really you know decades old that's
true to me in 42 but since I was 42 yeah
many decades many difference many this
can pull of decades I could talk about
many okay you've had more - okay handful
of thank you thank you several decades
the one handful of decades I've suffered
a major depressive episode I would say
at least every six months and in the
last five or six years with many
different interventions we could talk
about not just pharmacological have not
experienced a single extended depressive
episode that's very atypical and that's
the personal driver behind looking at
some of these compounds that in the
literature and certainly anecdotally
whether it's at a therapeutic dose or a
large dose or a micro dose seem to
impart lasting anti-anxiety so anxiety
and anti-depressive properties and this
has been looked at at places like Johns
Hopkins and others it's and what makes
it so compelling to me is that you have
many what would be considered
intractable often intractable
psychiatric conditions
eating disorders like anorexia highest
mortality rate of any psychiatric
disorder addiction of various types
nicotine opiates obsessive-compulsive
disorder depression chronic anxiety
which may actually all be variations of
the same thing when you look at
functional MRIs and so on this and it's
specifically something called the
default mode Network so personally is
the depression to a functional MRIs here
you actively monitor the brain activity
that's right and while you know what the
person is thinking that's right so you
can track it that's exactly right
or after you've administered them a
given drug and the the psychedelic
scientific exploration was suspended
effectively late sixties early seventies
onward when the Nixon administration
placed many of the classic psychedelics
in schedule one for political and not
scientific reasons schedule one meaning
high potential for abuse no known
medical application heroin heroin yeah
exactly with with with corresponding
penalties so that's the Dale James
yeah the legal side of corresponding
penalties no jails yeah the legal side
effects are very very stuff so so that's
the personal so you think that tabled
what could have been more exploratory
research that could have helped people
is that almost 100% not only not just
for a therapeutic applications because
you find that in some instances you'll
let's take a nicotine addiction as an
example Matt Johnson dr. Matthew Johnson
at Hopkins has looked very closely at
nicotine addiction and with I want to
say two or three administration's of
psilocybin which is thought to be the
most active molecule from a psychedelic
perspective in magic mushrooms so-called
magic mushrooms selasa tea mushrooms you
can synthesize psilocybin administer it
two or three times with psychotherapy
this is not a daily drug and six months
later I want to say six months later in
this study which people can look up
there was around an 80% abstinent right
abstinence rate six month post
compare that to the current best
intervention a drug available which is
going to be taken constantly and that
might be high 20 high 20s or low 30s
with some yeah it's some people some
home it's some but not statistically
strongly yeah you're looking at a huge
improvement and with the anti-depressive
effects and many subjects can also last
on the order of months that's from one
or two administrations this is not a
daily drug so my interest in this is in
part hopefully funding science that
helps with therapeutic applications with
what people consider unsolvable
psychiatric issues because we got all
these breakthroughs in cardiology
immunology and so on and it's a tough
nut to crack it is and psychiatry
literally yes so there's really been
very little aside from SSRIs and more
recently ketamine that could be
considered breakthroughs of sorts and
and they don't necessarily in the case
of SSRIs work for everyone and not for
it necessarily long period of time and a
a more fundamental exploration of
consciousness so there's the therapeutic
application and then there's the
exploration of consciousness itself
which I find equally certainly intersect
we better close out this part of our
show now but stick around for our final
segment that we wrap up my conversation
with entrepreneur Tim Ferriss who will
be right back welcome back to Startalk
we've been following my conversation is
Tim Ferriss let's get back to that
conversation now tell me more about life
hacking just just yeah what does that
mean life hacking my life is fine why do
I want to hack it yeah you may not have
to you may not have to life hacking as
look at who is right to get to be like
act what kind of profile what's the
profile if someone who feels that they
are not optimizing efficiency in one or
more areas of their life so if there are
symptoms of overwhelm a wise efficiency
the measure of what is good it's not
it's not but that's a symptom that can
then lead to apply in certain toolkit I
don't use the word life hack much but
it's a term that is broadly used to
represent any type of tool or shortcut
that allows you to achieve a result or
automate certain things also achieving a
result much like computer hackers okay
okay so then alright so it's not that I
live a perfectly efficient life is that
there's certain tasks that I could have
gotten done a little faster better
simpler and the life hack helps that and
that gives me time to do other things
yeah and go fair cuz it's totally fun
yeah I think that's that's fair in hack
is really a versatile word and I'll give
you an example first just to set the
context like you said efficiency you can
do a lot of stupid things quickly well
that does not make good make you wise
doesn't make you wise and it doesn't
make the st. important right so I do
think that what you do is more important
than how you do anything right you need
to choose your targets first and then
apply a good process but life hack or a
hack could be applied to language
learning anything that has a lot of
assumptions and baggage and decades and
decades of the same teaching or the same
approach to learning is generally ripe
for some type of assumption testing and
that's where you find approaches that
may be much much more effective and
interesting to know why not admit that
maybe because it's been done this way
forever that is the best way someone
already hacked it a hundred times
yeah and no more hacks left for you that
might be true but that's an that is a
hypothesis worth disproving right if I
get a Karl Popper like Sciences
falsification all right great
let's vote let's try to falsify we get
the worst case scenario is we figure out
okay guess what this painful rote
approach that we have is the best of the
best of breed sorry pal there's a notion
there's no fast shortcut through this
all that relates to meta learning it
does relate to meta learning in what way
well meta learning is a is a systematic
way of approaching learning a
new skill or subject and does it assume
you don't know anything about it at
first he does there's a colleague of
mine he said he was never good at
swimming and I said well how do you know
well the first time I tried I I flailed
in the water and everyone passed me in
the race so I just gave up so that was
his measure that he would never be good
in swimming yeah but I was not convinced
of that oh sure
well that's not that's not much of a
dancer what is this like a really crappy
data set no we're assuming that your
first time out if you don't shine yeah
then you'll never be great later on yeah
and I think a lot of people who could
continue to ascend if their interest and
ambition directs them yeah so you you
have ways of making this happen I do and
it's it's I'll give you a very concrete
example because you mentioned swimming
so I couldn't swim meaning from two one
into the pool back let's just define it
that way until I was in my early
thirties I grew up by the ocean and I
had a huge fear of sharks sure that's
not your shark that's why you don't want
to swear off of drowning I had an eight
and very CUTE fear of drowning but
anxiety and anxiety about it and I did
not have confidence in my ability to
swim and you look it looks bad if you're
a thirty years old they got those little
floaties on you're obese if you're not
gonna be ladies it's not the best
approach and what changed that is a
friend introduced me to a method of
swimming that was a very
counterintuitive called total immersion
and what total immersion did is what I
also do in other fields so there was
there was a kingship and that is they
test assumption good tactics apply to
more than one that feels yeah that's
right and one of the approaches that
that you would take and this is a little
out of warning or one of the pieces of
metal learning if you are a novice or if
you're an intermediate trying to get to
advanced or advanced trying to get to
super advanced is to ask what the
failure points might be what are the
factors that could cause me to quit
specifically and in my case what were
the things I disliked about the lessons
I take it because I had tried lessons
not just once but many times because I
had a friend hold
countable we assigned each other in new
year's resolutions in mine was to do a
one kilometer race swimming swimming and
I couldn't do one one pool length full
length and total immersion does this
with swimming so what are some of the
failure points kicking so I had been
taught when I took lessons here's a kick
board kick your way we're gonna warm up
and I would flame out before I I would
flame out and be completely exhausted
within five minutes of starting and that
was the end of the lesson I couldn't
even continue with the technical
training right so they put conditioning
/ warm-up before
technique number two fear of drowning
how do you remove your drowning don't
practice some deep water practice it in
a shallow into the pool all right what
else breathing how many people do you
know I know tons who can kind of swim
around but they have no semblance of
rhythm with any kind of breathing almost
everyone breathing let's take breathing
out all right now if you remove those
things how might you practice you could
practice by kicking off a wall in
shallow water and practicing colliding
so that you develop the proper fuselage
position right and left and begin to
understand what hydrodynamics because
what most people swim they keep their
heads up and ninety percent of their
energy is going into keeping their heads
up and less than ten percent is actually
propelling them forward so this this
would be an example of how you can do it
but that means every next thing requires
that a U and a kind of analysis unique
to that subject no it doesn't oh wow it
sounds like it because I want to learn
how to play the piano okay I had lessons
when I was 13 mmm and then I stopped
yeah but I got a piano at home I want to
end it I stare down every day the
towpath stood the Undine homework you
have the unknown homework now and
jumping into that is not about awkward
dynamics it's not but let me let me back
up and zoom out and just give you the
framework because I think it'll be
helpful so the framework for Medel
learning that I use it's not the only
way but it does apply to a lot is dis as
an acronym dsss are ants of D and 3 s's
the first step and I can apply this to
you can easily apply this to music I've
seen it applied to music or to language
for instance
Construction is taking this thing learn
the piano right or learn Japanese and
breaking it into constituent parts what
are the pieces right body posture scales
in the case of language you could have
vocabulary grammar oral fluency writing
you can start to piece it out
deconstruction then the next step is
selection which is when you do an 80/20
analysis of the material they've broken
out looking for these the 20% of say
exercises or practices it will produce
80% of what your desired outcome is this
is very easy to do in I would imagine
music and certainly in language because
you can look at word frequency lists so
it's not 400 words in English language
love word free basic lists it's not 100
using words it's like 1500 words boom
yeah most communication is just a few
hundred words you know yeah and then you
have this is the part that we were just
talking about is sequencing putting
things in a logical progression and that
is the the secret sauce I think that
gets ignored by a lot of people were
even very good at what they do is this
is the sequencing and the last one and
this this might help with the undone
homework and the piano is stakes so
setting up consequences so that you have
a reward and or a punishment that are
more rewarding or more uncomfortable
than sitting down to practicing that's
that the lab rat put a little a little
cookie on the set it could be a cookie
it could be a cookie I'll give you a
great example the one way you could set
up stakes is by putting together let's
just say it's for weight loss you could
put together a betting pool or you have
five friends this alright we're gonna
put in a hundred bucks and by the end of
the quarter we're going to do before and
afters we're gonna measure our body fat
percentage whoever drops percentage-wise
the most gets the pot in that case you
have a reward and you have the loss
aversion which is very very powerful as
a motivator and we're competitive yeah
if you're competitive so it's indeed
that is why the stakes something that
you customize right and there are tools
out there like stick is a nice one st
ice
kay-kay calm we can talk about that
where you pick an anti charity that your
money goes to if if you don't hit your
oh here we go huh
chatter do you dislike Bob I just it
never occurred to me that surely there
are opposite charities out there no yeah
that's pretty scary yeah yeah for sure
do you see a charity oh that's the right
thing that we all agreed to do you got
another one that's trying to not make
that happen
yeah toto and there are there are
different ways to approach this question
of motivation and behavioral change
which is what I've done kinda from day
one but that the point being that I
recall hearing story of this kind of
stage let's call it life coach who said
he could he could cure any kind of
phobia and he had this woman come up she
said I've never been able to get past
climbing ladders or stairs I said all
right here's the ladder and he did some
whiz-bang boudu and she climbed the
ladder and came down and he's like and
you see ladies and gentlemen doesn't
Donnie started giving himself all this
credit and she said yeah you know I'm
really happy because my husband told me
if I climb the ladder he'd give me a
hundred bucks but well maybe it's not
the stage magician maybe it's the
incentive so so that's the framework and
it does it does work for a lot I noticed
that one of the friends of stark talk
you had in your in your interview book
Janna Levin
and so which cheek was she or my cheap
in your token astrophysicist in that
book we all needed token expertise of
cosmologists know yeah she's had one
should ever cosmology friend everybody
should have a cosmology friend she is
she is a is a is a great not just
thinker but communicator mm-hmm and I I
really feel like she thinks about how
she communicates right yes right so it
comes out it's like wow I've just been
taught by someone I was really thought
this through
yeah and we met through Maria Popova who
runs a cycle brain pickings and she is
also someone who thinks about thinking
and thinks about communicating important
concepts and does a great job of it and
I I think that part of the reason I
meir both of them so much is they
recognize that knowledge held is one
thing knowledge shared and then
knowledge shared which is actionable in
some way are three different things and
they do a really great job
I think of explaining potentially
complex subjects very simply you don't
frustrates me people who read a lot yeah
but then don't share anything that they
learned yeah like people read four books
a day and they just sit there can you
share something yeah yeah did you learn
something is that wisdom is there some
not just like reading yeah and so I
think I don't know do I get to say that
that's selfish of them I think it's it's
it's it's may be selfish and also
delusional in the sense that if you
can't teach something you'd I don't
think you understand it
so yeah that's said that's what that's a
good one yeah yeah people have said that
so if you want to test your retention
and understanding of that book you just
read let's see you try to explain it
somebody right right then we'll know
then we'll know I don't know yeah
absolutely it's time to wrap up this
episode of star talk I hope you enjoyed
listening to this conversation with the
one and only Tim Ferriss if any of his
contagious energy passion and curiosity
emanated through this podcast the world
will be better off for it I think
there's not enough people like Tim
Ferriss in the world and you know that
because he's so popular and yet his
message on some level is so simple it's
how to make the most of who and what you
are how to derive happiness from it how
to bring fulfillment to your life your
work your home imagine if we all just
thought that way and felt that way how
different this world would be you've
been listening to Startalk radio I've
been your host Neil deGrasse Tyson your
personal astrophysicist and as always I
did you
[Music]